hello guys I'm Ryan right I'm Andrew
Andrew and I today are gonna review the
final film in the trilogy from the 70s
Star Wars Return of the Jedi thumbnail
Andrew I'm adding a lightsaber I don't
know how to add a lightsaber sorry for
the thumbnail guys yeah so return to the
Jedi I love some of the action scenes in
this movie so much one of my favorite
action sequences of all time hands down
is the moment Luke and Leia they hop on
like those speeder bikes and they're
going through the forest out of the
whole chase sequence to this day holds
up like it's still a great action
sequence and you're not like this feels
so outdated you know like it looks
wonderful that's all I was saying it's
like wow this still looks fantastic and
I really feel like I'm flying through
the air with them and I couldn't believe
was 1983 they filmed that it completely
holds up like you said a couple things I
like to the cinematography in the film I
thought was really I thought it was
really well done they did a great job
holding the camera still especially on
action scenes so yeah very clear to tell
the effects really still hold up like we
said for the most part there's a few
scenes obviously here in there where it
looks like the 80s definitely that scene
on Endor the battle above Endor the
lightsaber duel between Vader and Luke I
mean there's definitely a lot of
positive things that's from the
characters there's still them there's
their great Han Luke Luke and Chewie and
Leia it was a nice way to end it for
sure I felt they could have been a
definite was a safe way yeah movie I
felt played it way too safe for sure
Empire Strikes Back ends on one of the
edgiest notes you could have ended on
yes some of the best practical effects
I've ever seen is this movie Return of
the Jedi especially in that first half
hour at Jabba's palace yeah on the Sail
Barge - oh yeah like all of them made me
kind of want to vomit
they were so disgusting in a realistic
way that Java world was cool only thing
that was bothering me a little bit with
c-3po they've made him way too whimsical
that relief yeah that was like too much
like he was funny in the first two
because you c-3po this time around it
was like let's really give him a lot of
[ __ ] jokes Jabba's palace though I
love that environment like it's like the
gangster world of tattooing
and like I said earlier my favorite
character and javis palace by far
salacious crumbs the monkey lizard I
love that character it's so fun and
there's a lot of great characters in
there and if you were fortunate enough
to not see the special edition you got
to finally see Jabba for the first time
while watching this movie instead that
crappy version that you saw in and you
know who lives up to the disgusting all
tation burger and yeah he is malicious
soulless and he's just this giant
[ __ ] fat monster and yeah and the
puppeting on Java is just really well
done again a like I said on the Empire
review if you didn't do the puppeting
right for like Yoda it wouldn't have
worked it would have taken us way out of
the scene but again the puppeting was
very well done it on these films
Princess Leia's outfit oh the she got in
shape after that to this day it's like I
know you're a rather much older lady now
but looking at you back in the 80s they
were banging dan we're banging not as
sexy but for sure cool when she was
addressed as a bounty hunter yeah and
she freed Han I thought that was such
cool gear she was wearing a really
really well done today and they
definitely made Leia um sexy that too
but I love how they never have her as a
damsel in distress she's always a badass
yeah
who's the one who kills Jabba right is
it what is it hon or look no it's its
Leia she takes the iron and wraps and
rounds like that was it that was a good
choice of who to kill Java yes because
people might have been like pawns Polly
gonna kill Java yeah then no Luke's
gonna do it but she's the one who really
deserved it for being a [ __ ] like
slave yeah you know it's fine you said
from what I understand Carrie Fisher
like told the director Richard Marquand
and the writers she basically told them
like if I'm gonna wear this sex labour
outfit the slave outfit then I'm gonna
be the one who kills job and I that was
absolutely right decision to ask Carrie
Fisher do that they definitely made Leia
badass which I like however I hate the
scene when Luke tells her that Leia is
her last his brother well you didn't
think her reaction was believable the
finding out Darth Vader was her father
and Luke was her brother the one now it
was
verbal Andrew it was horrible and I
greatly disagree with him I don't know
how you truly feel about that while
watching the scene I kind of somewhat
understood where they were going but I
was like this is unbelievable how could
she not how is she reacting so calm to
finding out Darth Vader is her father
and the man you made out with one scene
was your brother from a previous movie
going it's just total calm reaction like
I'm like shouldn't your world be like so
much it was adjusting to it yeah it's
like you can't argue that she was in
shock because she wasn't yeah she was
like I'm surprised but I kind of knew
already you know I think of when Luke
found out Darth Vader was his dad or you
that reaction [ __ ] awesome [ __ ]
awesome
[ __ ] awesome Oh totally offended Leia
and Luke their scene I was like this
seems like I have a soap opera right now
the whole time even after they know that
I still feel like they have sexual
chemistry yeah no I'm not gonna argue
that it was definitely uh-huh yeah
that's pretty hot maybe some brothers
and sisters are not my thing but I mean
I get Luke will use the Force on that
one right oh I mean after seeing her in
the sex and the slave thing who can
blame them right but still um sister or
not
yeah I didn't buy that reaction at all I
I would imagine someone finding out
Darth Vader it's the most evil man in
the world is your father you're gonna
freak out you the number one enemy
you're the leader of the Rebel Alliance
yeah you know I agree that definitely
took me out of it another big but
Wednesday negative but just something
that just didn't feel Star Wars and took
me out of the phones the Ewok do you
want I mean and again from originally
they were supposed to be Wookiees not
Ewok that would have been cool Oh would
have been so much better and I guess
they went back to that and Revenge of
the Sith when we were on the planet
Kashyyyk we had a bunch of rookies but
we would have gotten practical effect no
no no no I'm just saying he ended up
going back to it but I would have rather
him George Lucas and Richard Marquand
added wookies to this I guess the reason
was they couldn't afford the the
costumes it cost too much much yeah they
can't afford something two films are the
most successful films yeah I know and
they can't get a little bit of extra
money definitely a lazy excuse Return of
the Jedi as a kid growing up it was by
far my favorite
one who argued with me that Empire or
New Hope were better I still enjoyed
this movies but I did an arguments on
why return was way better now having
viewed those as an adult Empire and New
Hope or JIT I mean they're just this
return of the jedis meant for kids like
really I'm watching them like this they
PG did way too much like now I felt like
Empire has like an edgy like it felt
like an edgy pg-13 film from my
understand it still PG right yes they're
all PG except for Revenge of the Sith
and the new one force away yeah
everything else is PG so when it came to
the tone of it all it seemed like okay a
no good characters ever seem truly in
danger died this the sense of humor
about it the light-hearted like it was
so light-hearted like the Ewoks it's man
I'm gonna murder those kids I'm havin
fun there all right yeah you can hey we
were all kids once right yeah but I
wasn't a disrespectful little [ __ ] one
thing I didn't like was they they go to
the Ewok world for like way too [ __ ]
long yeah they go there way too [ __ ]
yeah I know I'm like their tribe is not
that interesting we're spending way too
much time feeling good with these guys
oh yeah it felt like hook mm oh no I was
thinking that it was like once Peter Pan
show yeah you got like how they went to
the deuce s ex machina c-3po is the god
cool I guess but I don't mean they never
really also when to explanation why they
thought c-3po was a guy I will save one
cool scene in that whole thing was when
c-3po is basically laying the plot of
new hope and Empire used telling the the
Ewoks what is basically their journey
has been up to this point I thought that
was pretty cool I don't know like the
violence and it could have been better
to like like Leia gets shot at one point
arm and the other and then you know she
saves the day when she shoots the two
stormtroopers let me just see what she's
ever really a meme after that there was
no consequence you happen and you just
got shot man and also we were talking
about this earlier I mean and again
we're happy that they ended it on a very
happy note that's always nice and dandy
how many of the of our main characters
are good characters hide in the film not
work
yeah none and did you truly feel any of
them were really in danger no especially
up against the stormtroopers are up
against because the Ewoks were like
taking them out with like a rock yeah
and I'm like these these suits are
designed to withstand their
Hermer yeah [ __ ] you walk throwing a
rock at you should not be making you
knocked over I get it when that's like a
bunch of logs easy whatever absolutely
no when when I'm seeing moments where
there slingshotting a rock and they're
like whoa like falling over now and then
catching the speeder bike yeah yeah no
no I'll agree with you there's
definitely a few inventive ways that
they where the logs came under the a 80s
tease and they had logs driving in there
was definitely when they worked together
it may have said yeah definitely worked
when you saw so loved ones going after
throwing rocks definitely didn't feel
believable but I will say another part
that really and got on me was when the
emperor said to Luke an alliance of my
best troops is awaiting them and then
you see teddy bears with rocks or
beating them it's it just took all the
tension away from me I felt in han Solo
and all their journey it felt like it
was all going according to plan most of
the time things were always turning out
okay there was no real danger other than
there's a Death Star that supposedly
works but they never told us why it's
worse yeah no I agree and also to add to
your point something I told you earlier
speaking about how all these characters
feel safe
Harrison Ford actually told George Lucas
halfway through shooting I want you to
kill my character I want you to kill me
off I don't exactly remember the reason
I just feel I think I remember reading
that Harrison Ford felt he'd done all he
could with the character and that was it
lucky for us he didn't die we get to see
him in a day or two but yeah it
definitely if it was a film that felt
very safe like an empire light don't
want to compare but you really felt a
moment I mean the characters were in the
lowest places they could be man there
was always crazy situation I love like
an empire when they can't get the
Malayan Falcon is not working they can't
get it to know those things these
situations they keep just get out of and
this it's like I don't care if there's
an aide TSD standing on I know they're
gonna get out of it yeah it just tension
just didn't feel the same I did like
this story of Luke Skywalker oh yeah
absolutely
when he does find out yeah he's a badass
I would like to have known how he became
super badass from Empire how he became
like Fe Jedi yeah cuz he even says do de
I've come back to complete the training
I know there was a year that went on
between phones oh I didn't understand
where that how we're all that amazing
how he became you know from when he
fought Vader to where we see him at the
beginning i J
is completely improved as a Jedi but
Mark Hamill does own that role oh he
does he's a big great thing about Luke
Skywalker's he's different in all three
films out of all the characters he's the
one who's definitively different in each
one of the films and he is like Jedi
Master at that point I like the cheesy
funds philosophical story of giving teo
inga and he's not doing it so I like
that I like that contrast and I didn't
for the most part like what happened
with Darth Vader one thing I thought was
weird was he really tried playing father
figure way too early on still like I
felt the actor in the suit was able to
their day vyd Prowse David Prowse was
able to convey a motion of a more
vulnerable Vader giving the script what
they needed
absolutely I'd say the best example of
what you just said when the scene where
the Emperor is forced lightening Luke to
death if you didn't see the blu-ray
version where Vader yells no was stupid
basically Luke is being forced lightning
to death and Vader is seeing and he has
to make a choice do I save my son who's
my only link to my dead and loving wife
Padme or do I keep serving this man who
keeps manipulating me and his and be his
puppet again you can't see Vader's eyes
the actor David Prowse just really
conveys the conflict yeah you can tell
he cannot stand watching his son being
electrocuted it was just such an amazing
job where you cannot see any of his
facial reaction it's incredible and then
when the blu-ray where they added the no
it's like oh I gotta say though man when
they show Vader like what he really
looks like underneath hmm good scene but
I felt like Vader was a little
mischievous I'm an overweight guy but
the guy they got for Vader
it was [ __ ] bit little puffy we're
gonna be nice we'll see I wasn't
expecting like such home fat Vader to be
honest and he looks skinnier when they
reach out him as the force ghost I
believe right oh you know I look totally
doing like this I agree with oh my god
why did they do that I would eat in my
product the most hated performance and
all saga my problem with that is Luke
Skywalker
ever met Anakin as as as Hayden
Christensen he only met Anakin when he
his dad was puffy daddy
why wasn't obi-wan Kenobi why was it
judge well I was in Ewan McGregor as
obi-wan why wasn't the digital Yoda it
was just confusing because many amusing
and it was unnecessary every unnecessary
area and I'm like you just took one of
the things I hate about the prequels and
added into a movie I loved at the end of
the day it still feels fun and it still
has a light-hearted vibe of like the
loving magic of Star Wars it still feels
like we're in the Star Wars universe
absolutely no we got our characters back
and also I'm really upset I didn't
mention this rather John Williams score
in the trilogy I can't even explain how
how much that score means to me and how
much it hits me every time I just hear
that music just the opening crawl yeah
you feel like it's just he did I mean he
just did an amazing job on all three
films and the music he had going on with
Vader and Luke are fighting and Luke's
letting his anger and rage on just such
epic beautiful music like I don't even
need to see the scene I can listen to
the music and I know exactly what's
going on he just really hits the spot on
John Williams is the best composer of
all time and just made Star Wars
extra-special with that music well guys
that's our review for Return of the Jedi
let's give a rating here Andrew I give
it three out of five [ __ ] sabers I'll
give it four 3.8 midi-chlorians right
does that many chlorines is that what
Lucas came up with to describe how a
Jedi has a hey you discovered Jedi guys
it's not the will of the force it's
medic Laurens right so in a condition
yeah you can subscribe to the real
rejects andrew has a channel now movie
source covers trailers movie reviews
will be coming up soon check it out it's
good stuff good discussions and you
didn't comment on my [ __ ] saber thing
was just thrown off I didn't expect you
to say that but that's an interesting
light saber did you uh you maybe for
Halloween you can show it off not to me
but maybe like on Twitter or something
and I can see what a [ __ ] saber is but I
haven't my imagination the bounce-off
you did for my joke was not worthy you
are not worthy of the dark side